c'est le premier procès visant l'ordre
du temple solaire il doit s'ouvrir mardi
devant le tribunal correctionnel de
grenoble un seul prévenu le chef
d'orchestre michel tabachnik dont on ne
sait pas s'il se présentera et 16
cadavres retrouvés dans le vercors la
veille de noël joël bruandet et
guillaume fautrat 23 décembre 95 au
lieu-dit la serre du pasj dans le massif
du vercors tôt dans la matinée les
gendarmes découvrent 16 cadavres
partiellement calciné 16 personnes
disparues depuis une semaine
seize nouvelles victimes de l'ordre du
temple solaire n'ont pas encore été
touchées se trouvent toujours la
position que j'avais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire en forme de soleil
disposés en fait en étoile un sac
poubelle sur la tête ils pensaient
s'embarquer pour une nouvelle vie toutes
les victimes dont trois enfants ont reçu
une ou plusieurs balles dans la tête
[Musique]
sur le parking en contrebas de la
clairière quatre voitures immatriculées
en suisse et en france elles
appartiennent aux victimes
mais les indices sont minces les
enquêteurs ont il appert à un suicide
collectif
y at il eu intervention extérieure deux
questions au coeur de l'instruction
selon le magistrat chargé de l'enquêté
deux hommes parmi les victimes auraient
été les exécutants du massacre
l'architecte suisse andré frier de lit
est cet homme
le français jean-pierre l'ardent chez un
inspecteur de police après avoir drogué
puis a battu les 14 autres adeptes
il se serait suicidé d'une balle de 357
magnum
l'ancien champion de ski jean vernet a
perdu sa femme et l'un de ses fils dans
le massacre du vercors avec alain son
autre fils il met en doute les
conclusions de l'instruction et la thèse
du crime en vase clos
six ans après les faits il cherche
toujours à comprendre qu'il est évident
que il ya un problème de crédibilité il
ya
il avait avec quelque chose mais c'est
maintenant son cas du lait ça nous
emmène pas si loin ils sont quand même
tombés dans un système gt qui était
dramatique
un système qui devait leur permettre de
gagner l'étoile sirius rejoindre ce
qu'ils appellent le père par
transformation de la matière le fameux
transit une des nombreuses formules
ésotérique qu'on retrouvait lors des
cérémonies occultes de la secte les
adeptes de l'ordre du temple solaire se
voyait comme une élite chevaleresque et
mystique
certains affirment et même être la
réincarnation des templiers des 12e et
13e siècles
mais là messieurs bonsoir 23 morts a
chéri le massacre du vercors en rappelle
un autre
quatorze mois plus tôt au canada et en
suisse 53 personnes au total ont trouvé
la mort dans les décombres de ce chalet
du valais les cordes luc jouret médecin
homéopathe belge et du français joseph
di mambro les deux gourous de l'eau ts
pour la justice suisse les acteurs de la
tuerie faisait partie des victimes
elle a donc rendu un non lieu la justice
française
elle a retenu le rôle du chef
d'orchestre suisse michel tabachnik le
juge d'instruction luc fontaine a relevé
que ce proche de 10 membres au centre
sur cette photo était l'auteur de
nombreux textes servant à conditionner
les adeptes des textes où il était déjà
question de sirius le chef d'orchestre
ne sait pas aujourd'hui s'il viendra à
son procès la loi française autorise en
effet depuis le 1er mars à se faire
représenter par son avocat
bouc émissaire ou numéro 3 de l'eau ts
le tribunal s'est donné 15 jours pour
trancher
maintenant trois descentes 95 au lieu
dit la serre du pasj dans le massif du
vercors pour dans la matinée les
gendarmes découvrent 16 cadavres
partiellement calciné
16 personnes disparues depuis une
semaine
nouvelle victime
mais n'ont pas encore été touchées se
trouvent toujours dans la position que
j'ai un bouquet tout à l'heure c'est à
dire en forme de soleil
disposés en fait en étoile un sac
poubelle sur la tête ils pensaient
s'embarquer pour une nouvelle vie tous
les midis
[Musique]
ont reçu 2
plusieurs balles dans la
sur le parking en contrebas de la
clairière quatre voitures immatriculées
en suisse et en france
mais les indices sont les enquêteurs il
après un suicide collectif
y at il une intervention extérieure deux
questions au coeur de l'instruction
selon le magistrat chargé de l'enquêté
deux hommes parmi les victimes auraient
été les exécutions du massacre
l'architecte suisse andré frieh et de
lits est cet homme
le français jean-pierre la revanche est
un inspecteur de police après avoir trop
et puis a battu les 14 entre à défaut il
se serait suicidé d'une balle de 357
magnum
l'ancien champion de ski jean cernay a
perdu sa femme et l'un des fils dans le
massacre du vercors avec alain
une entreprise
conclusions de l'instruction et la thèse
du crime en vase clos
six ans après les faits il cherche
toujours à comprendre qui est évident
que
il ya un problème de crédibilité il ya
il avait il avait quelque chose mais ces
gens sont crédules et ça ne les emmène
pas si loin ils sont quand même tombés
dans un système qui était qui était
dramatique qui devait leur permettre de
gagner l'étoile sirius rejoindre ce
qu'ils appellent le père marc
transformation de la matière le famine
auzits
une des nombreuses formules ésotérique
pour
desserrez milieu culte de la secte les
adeptes de dollars du temps
je voyais pas une élite chez certains
la sueur des campings et des pieds
mais là messieurs bonsoir 23 morts à
cherry dans la broye fribourgeoise
baltringue mort aux granges dauphin
vantaux en valais ce pourrait être un
bilan provisoire mais c'est déjà reçues
la mort dans les décombres du chalet du
valais les corps du jour est médecin
homéopathe belles nuances et joseph
dimanche
[Musique]
on la justice suisse les acteurs de la
touline faisait partie
la justice française est la rue dont
deux rouges pochette orient michèle
tabarot
cette photo était l'auteur
mexes de servante accusés
et vous
déjà qu elle aussi lieu saint
le chef d'orchestre nous c'est pas
aujourd'hui s'il viendra son procès la
loi française représentée par son amant
de la numéro 3 91%
[Musique]